vivre chaque moment comme le dernier
voilà une phrase bien clichés qu'on a vu
et entendu mille fois même si on ne
serait pas forcément dire où et quand je
vais essayer de dire en quel sens je la
trouve pourri et encaissant je la trouve
chouette elle est pourrie en ce sens
qu'elle ne veut pas dire grand chose de
précis en fait j'ai l'impression que la
compréhension spontanée de cette phrase
c'est en gros apprécié chaque instant de
l'existence comme on apprécie la
dernière bouchée d'un plat délicieux et
donc ça résonne avec ce drôle d'idée al
profite
c'est bizarre quand même c'est pas un
truc qu'on peut faire sur commande j'ai
l'impression et puis ça met la pression
j'en profite du moment sinon tu leur a
caché quoi gâcher
j'aurais gâcher un moment de ma vie
c'est horrible et en plus c'est sûrement
le meilleur moyen de gâcher le moment
puisque au lieu de le vivre l'esprit
léger
maintenant je me dis qu'il est possible
que je n'en profite pas assez mais
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
gachet selon quels critères évidemment
si on dit vivre chaque moment comme si
c'était le dernier pour dire profitant
au maximum
eh bien ça renvoie au critère dominant
de l'époque et de la société dans
laquelle on vit donc en l'occurrence
c'est probablement un truc d'intensité
ça revient à dire
concentre toi sur le moment pour en
faire un truc super excitant enivrant de
royan mais toute expérience qui ne se
hissera pas à une telle hauteur sera
synonyme de moments gâcher une autre
raison qui rend cette phrase stupide à
mes yeux c'est qu'elle fait comme si le
dernier moment de la vie était en fait
vécu comme le dernier moment d'être cool
au milieu de la vie en fait il est très
difficile d'imaginer dans quelle
disposition d'esprit en serait si on
savait avec certitude qu'on était en
train de vivre notre dernier instant en
tout cas si je devais imaginer quelque
chose ça ne ressemblerait pas à la
tension teintée de regrets anticipé qui
accompagne la dernière bouchée de mon
dessert préféré de la peur ou de
l'apaisement oui ça d'accord ça me
paraît déjà plus crédible
mais du coup vivre chaque moment dans la
panique qu'on va mourir juste après
c'est pas terrible vivre chaque moment
dans l'apaisement qui accompagne une
conscience contenter c'est super mais
c'est précisément difficile à atteindre
pour la plupart d'entre nous en revanche
il y a une interprétation de cette
phrase que j'aime beaucoup et qui la
rend bien plus joli à mes yeux vivre
chaque moment comme si c'était le
dernier
non pas au sens où la fin de ce moment
serait synonyme de fin de vie mais au
contraire comme si ce moment allait
durer une éternité vivre chaque moment
comme si la vie se mettaient en pause
indéfiniment
regardez la vie du point de vue de
l'éternité c'est à dire précisément
vivre le moment comme si on ne pouvait
rien attendre d'autre de la vie comme si
rien n'avait plus jamais changé en somme
vivre comme s'il n'avait rien de mieux à
espérer
bien sûr tous passent les choses vont et
viennent et j'aime garder à l'esprit que
rien n'est éternel
mais cette éternité fictive qu'on peut
essayer de projeter sur un moment est
intrigante
parce que l'on peut avoir tendance à
être tendues vers le moment suivant
savoir que les choses parce cela peut
entretenir cette disposition d'esprit
qui consiste à chercher la prochaine
stimulation on court après le plaisir ou
ont fui l'ennui ont fui la douleur etc
mais vivre ce moment comme s'il allait
durer l'éternité c'est peut-être
justement un moyen d'abandonner cette
course aussi c'est une incitation à voir
tout ce que ce moment à de riches sans
se mettre la pression pour en profiter
avant qu'il ne disparaisse